Let's do this!
Boom.
For the first time ever,
we're bringing together
an international all-star cast
of ex-islanders
ready for a second
chance at love.
And down for some
healthy competition.
Let the games begin!
I'm back whether
you like it or not!
This time, it's a whole
nother ball game.
I am so excited!
There is flavors from all
corners of the earth
in one villa.
It would be so fun
to fall in love
with somebody who’s
not from America.
Let's hope the girls
like an aussie
accent and they can
get down under.
Ahhh! I can't wait!
Get me looking hot, and get me
some six packs that I can touch.
Say I look good right?
If I want something,
I'm gonna get it.
I'm definitely gonna
give it my all.
I'll do whatever
it takes to win.
If I have to play dirty,
I'm gonna play dirty.
I need number one.
Not second, not third,
not fourth,
I want number one.
I think I got what it takes to
win the challenges
if they're like
physical, but if they're like
just about like being smart,
like I'm f***ed.
This time around,
I'mma give my heart,
but, I'm going for the money.
I'm going in looking for
the full package, right?
I love everything
that comes with love.
My heart's open!
It's gonna be explosive.
I'm so ready for the games.
All eyes are definitely gonna
be on me when I walk
into that villa.
Let's do this. It's game time.
I'm gonna be in this game.
Okay?